how does the search engine work that's a
hard question with a long answer because
it's hard because Google doesn't really
want you to know how it works because
whenever they tell you spammers try and
use all of the knowledge to kind of make
the results go how in half the list so
you you don't want to they don't want us
to know how it works and there's a long
answer because there's been sixty years
of research into information retrieval
on how to find documents in computers
and before that there was hundreds of
years of research into libraries for how
do you index a library illai bringing
that place through you have real
physical books in it
what's the link to libraries libraries
were a big place full of books he wants
to find and no way should look in the
library to find them you created an
index and you just read through that
index and go okay I need to go to the
fifth floors over there so then when we
started search through computers that
was a big digital space with lots of
files in it and to know where we should
look to find the file we wanted again it
creates an index to say go over there
into that folder and then when it comes
to search engines the web is a massive
digital place and then to know where we
should look in the web for the things
want to find again they create an index
so the history of how things were done
in libraries affect how we do how we
search the computers and that affects
how we search through the web system is
that it works in a bit differently but
there have been do Decimal type
approaches to do different things like
category browsing rather than web
searching let's go back to the 60s and
70s when people were thinking how can we
quickly go through files and computers
so this imagine we have five documents
here so here we have five files which
we're trying to search through to find
out which one is most about someone
talking about their horse so we've
searched for the words my horse hoping
the most people talking about their
horses and these five documents have
those words in different mass times so
document one has got the word mine at
twenty five times two has got mine at
five times but new they mentioned the
word horse document three says my and
horse both ten times
document four has 18 miles and five
horses and document five is any about
the word mind not that horses and so the
first thing you would do is just do term
frequency
TF term frequency and you're measuring
just how many times each word is
mentioned in there so this gets a score
of twenty five five twenty and so on
which is fine in principle and the idea
makes sense but in this set the word my
is overwhelming everything so in fact
document
one is the most relevant one with a
score 25 because it's got the word mind
more than this one has my aunt horse put
together so this is a problem this is
not the one that's most about horses but
it's the one with the highest score so
the next most obvious step for many
people would say well let's say okay it
needs to have both of those words in it
but for us to give it anything so now
this makes a bit more sense these two
are the only ones to get a good score
and they're both mentioned the word
horses which is great so another
approach to this would have been just to
rather than say okay we'll do some logic
and say that's the best way of doing it
well try a different approach where we
say why don't we undermine how important
the word Myers semi is in every document
so it doesn't really help us with
anything so if we just divide the score
that the word my produced for each one
by the number of documents it's in then
we suddenly have a much lower score for
the word mine might has less of an
impact let me call this inverse document
frequency so as we're dividing it by the
number of documents when you do this for
every search term so my divided by five
horse / tooth it's only in two documents
so this means that this one which is
really about my but not about horses
suddenly only gets a score of five then
the next one suddenly goes down to one
because there's five documents in there
this gets cut down to at seven this one
gets cut down as well we end up with a
score of six point one and then this one
goes right down to three cuz it's not
important and this works really well
because now the two which are about my
end horse get a bigger score and the
ones that were just about my get a much
lower score but we're still open to the
fact that a really important one about
my with her only mention horses once
might come up rather than just cutting
their things out so if it's in lots of
documents then we just care about it
less and the score it curates it hasn't
lesser impact on whether we choose it's
the most relevant document the other
good thing this has done is that it's
added slightly more weight to the word
horse to the fact that this word the
word horse has mentioned more in
document three gives it a higher score
now than document for them what we had
before so it's prioritized the document
there's more about horse as well as
undermining the amount of my in there
so then what a search engine has now
done is its found all the documents
decided how many words each of them is
it how many times each word is in there
and then giving it a score and cut it
down by the number of documents in so
it's not too much too influential if
it's no important and this is actually
really easy you can do this in 50 lines
of Python it's just not very fast
so the question is how do you make this
faster and so what they do to make this
faster as they build this thing called
index which you mentioned earlier they
build a text file which just has all of
these numbers pre-programmed into it and
so in fact it counts how many times
every word that they know about is in
document one and they're all in a table
ready to access and they can just use
that so then every time you search they
don't have to read all the documents
again count number of words in there
again because that's the slowest bit
they just look at the pre calculated
numbers for everything
and so this index is an important aspect
of keeping track of all the documents in
which words are in there and that index
will have all of these numbers we've
calculated so far in there so how many
documents the word horses in which is
two and how many times it's in each of
those documents so because this approach
is pretty simple there's a number of
things which are wrong with it and so
there's number things we can do to make
it even better one major problem mostly
is if you have really really long
documents like this one might be really
long which is why it has the word mine
at so many times then they're just going
to likely get a bigger score than all
the rest cuz they're longer so then we
can do is you can calculate the
proportion of the document that's about
the horse rather than the exact number
of times it's mentioned
so then you're comparing every document
on an equal proportion rather than
allowing big documents to change it you
can use stop words is another approach
so stop words say well there's not even
any point in searching for the word
because it isn't everything saying the
word to and and they're gonna get a low
score whatever you do so let's just not
even bother checking for a cuz that
saves us time you can also look at
stemming so one major challenge we often
get is that you want to find documents
that are about running but you search
for the word run and you want the word
running to come back or vice versa so if
you search for running you want all the
ones about running there so you just
have all of those merged down just to
word run and then you search for that
concept every time regardless of what
they type in run or running you might
also want to know about how near the
words are to each other so it might well
be that this document over here which
has got ten for my intent for horse is
not really about my horse is about my
cat and someone else's horse and so you
give a boost to the scores if they
happen to be near to each other so if
every time my and Horst come together at
the same time you give them a bonus
then if this was only came together at
one time my horse
and that's only got a bonus point at one
it's up to eight but if every time
horses mentioned there it came with my
you'd get five bonus points and that's
now eleven point five and suddenly this
is the more relevant document because it
said mine horse together and not just at
random times so this means that if you
the documents would say my horse get a
bigger score than documents that say in
my lovely horse which gets a bigger
score than the documents would say my
friend looks like a horse because
they're further and further away and so
they're less and less joined together
and what you want then the final thing
really finds some search engines might
do is they might start to search for
concepts rather than specific words so
it might be that a document which has
the word Pony in it comes back regularly
all the time with my pony my pony my
pony in so that's kind of like the ones
my horse my horse my horse so it might
be more relevant to one only had my
horse once in it so you can start to say
well if we have one which was my pony
document six for which there's no much
space then that had minus 6 times pony
at six times so when you divide it by
the number of documents my only got a
small school so we're tf-idf we're at
four point two but because I said my
pony together every time we get some
bonus points you end up with a score
that's actually making that one more
relevant than this one because that said
my horse once they said my pony six
times that was said my horse five times
and so you're getting scores which
promote words which are similar but not
exactly the same in order to find words
which are similar to each other to do
this to bring pony in rather than just
horse well they need to do is something
called latent semantic analysis or other
forms of looking back through your index
and what they do is they say the index
for a pony is looking a lot index for
horse every time pony comes up it's also
with field and horses always with field
ponies always with show horses always
with show ponies always with a pet
horses always with pet so these seem to
be very similar concepts in our index so
let's just motion together into a super
concept yeah there's many opportunities
for that to go wrong and so what the way
I explained it is kind of a simple way
of explaining latent semantic analysis
but there's many more advances to kind
of deciding how much of a similarity do
you need for them to be considered
probably related and there's other ways
to consider them to be properly related
so there are similar words in the
dictionary
some other for Soros which puts them
close together deserve humor never get
involved in this to check things or and
so there are also semantic indexes where
people have said these words are
conceptually related and so you can use
those to help you understand which
concepts are related
this tf-idf analysis of documents has
kind of been a major stage in the 60
years of history of information
retrieval and so there's a lot more I
could tell you about how they've
improved this they started kept taking
probabilities that this document is
about this word rather than counts and
so there's a whole probabilistic
approach to it there's much more
complicated models about language which
we could go into but again we could do a
whole video is about those two topics so
what we're really interested in this
point now is how does a search engine
use this type of algorithm and is this
the only thing they use what other
metrics do they use and so what we'll go
into next is analyzing how search
engines work and how they can benefit
from how our web pages are designed but
if I just sent out an image of my dog
and I never sent out the original but
the camera took no one's going to know
it's been imperceptibly been changed
because they haven't got already in a
narrower environment of precursor of
open source and had in the jargon of a
few years later was egoless programming
in the sense that I wrote the code but
if somebody else can do it better to go
ahead